il y en a un autre qui a rendu il a
trouvé l'amour sur un plateau qu'est-ce
qu'il a fait jurer de se déplacer
c'est vrai il est tombé amoureux fou de
flavie flament on avait dû repasser les
images ya quatre ans et j'ai envie de le
revoir il avait chanté c'était pour une
émission oui les petits princes
exactement en direct sur tf1 dès petits
princes de lui
parce qu'avant tf1 faisait des émissions
sur des biscuits des tout choco tout ça
et toc benjamin castaldi a rencontré
c'est la première fois que vous vous
aviez vu se dit finalement ce moment là
on s'était croisé avant d'aller on avait
répété mais là le mot c'est un match et
dans les recettes annuelles étaient
célibataires familles
raconte le réalisateur
alors alors c'était pas son mari de
l'époque n'ont laissé aller thiam et que
signent
avec quelqu'un et quelqu'un avec un
animateur et un animateur à l'effet
ch'ti manu chao ou bravo merci
mais j'adorerais manuelles jeux latorre
mais alors que tout le monde le savait
pas moi c'était connu non non
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
et
en plus je les adore et miley c'est un
super mois emmanuel chain a toujours
tiré sain mais le savez proches que ça
mais moi j'étais même pas dans le métier
moi je veux c'est des journées des gens
n'ai
jamais raconté c'est que la première
témoin de ce coup de foudre ça et éveil
beinheim noms ont travaillé ensemble sur
tf1 on était sur l'émission était
méritée et j'ai débarqué dans sa loge du
sud dans une mer de noir je viens
d'avoir un coup de foudre de fou et je
vais tout balancer je vais changer lui
ai dit attends je dit judith tu te
calmes tout de suite mais descend de
deux étages ok tu as eu un coup de
foudre ça peut arriver par les
contrats dans le caniveau dans un coup
de contrat à coups de canif dans le
contrat d'escale méthode que j'ai connu
il est impulsif abu garda [ __ ] en
l'air tout le qui avait neuf mois
à peine
[Rires]
je le dis je
j'aimerais vraiment ajoute à bordeaux
cette séquence en différents points
alors donc il y avait déjà un enfant lui
oui si vous l'avez tout enfant il a
désormais imminente en dominant mais dj
mehdi va prendre des vacances va te
reposer faire un truc une thalasso à
machin va te reposer comme ça tu
victoire à l'esprit clair et tu verras
si c'est un coup de coeur réelle ou si
c'est vraiment une passe année tu vas
pas [ __ ] en l'air toute ta vie de
couple avec ta ferme et tout ça bien et
bah il est parti je suis parti quand je
suis parti donc en vacances avec ma
femme et j'ai tenu trois jours je suis
parti j'ai de les laisser en vacances
elle aussi eu un coup de foudre pour
vous alors là oui alors on va revoir la
séquence et je veux que vous nous
racontiez tout depuis le moment vous
avez chanté jusqu'au moment où vous
l'avez retrouvé paul saissac à regarder
et regardez bien essayer de déceler le
coup de foudre
pour déceler le coup de foudre est très
simple vous voyez ce qui s'était passé
dans cette émission autres gillet
fattouche et c'est tout le contraire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
comme des hirondelles
tellement tu
c
depuis
aimer
[Musique]
une étoile je suis un mauvais
quelques années plus tard on va s'aimer
devenu on va payer
en bas de page
cette année
on va payer brûlé là
[Applaudissements]
oh
un
coup de foudre voilà là coup de foudre
et donc je le lance le lendemain je des
marques son bateau de célébrité je pars
là bas et je suis dans une merde noire
et je lui dis elle m'a dit mais
calme-toi calme-toi il y avait des
vacances des moments de noël ouais donc
j'ai dit je vais joyeux noël bons
baisers de suis parti je suis parti j'ai
fait noël apprécié e marty
en thalasso avec ma femme et moi et je
suis parti on pas vu des vacances cela
dit vous allez voir rejoindre tes j'ai
tout quitté j'ai tout système 1,31 et
l'âge et un revers
excusez moi mais c'est une phrase une
gamme
[Rires]
et sans rigoler c'est pas une moule est
pas possible
donc et dont elle était donc après
l'annoncé rejoint pour tout vous dire on
se rejoint en normandie est la ferme
saint-siméon
un peu les amours secrets vers l amour
c'est un bosseur voilà près de sachets
ça a été de là c'était la folie pendant
pendant 4 2 en 4 ans celle que ses 84
ans a annoncé à son ch et 90 kg non non
non ça c'est en fait je place on peut
être celle deux ans je pense qu'on ait
été pris dans le tourbillon de
célébrités et de réussite elle était la
numéro une à tf1 assure j'étais numéro
un sur m6 en prime de marche on a fait
deux matches nuls à et après je pense
qu'on s'est fait manger par le système
honnêtement je pense tous les mois des
parts système c'est arrivé à gilles et
fatma et voilà je pense que le message a
été numéro 1 sur ses news
et après donc et après je pense que on
s'est fait bouffer par le truc mais mais
c'était assez mac à l'époque en avant le
couple
irene a fait ce
qui m'a mis la puce à l'oreille c'est
qu'un jour on dîne chez eux dans le dix
septième
et
raconter
non tu racontes
là d'avoir un caftan d'y croiser un
enfant qui établit
flamand était folle de colère parce que
tf1 venait d'être benjamin venait d'être
débauché sur tf1 c'est bien d'avoir
plein de prime il arrive est élue elle
devrait être hyper contente pour lui
c'est son mec il a une super carrière et
où il était folle de colère parce
qu'elle voulait qu'un concurrent arriver
à ça c'est moche et 7 un peu le début de
la fin se coupait les jambes comment
même bien on adore ma télé celle d'abord
sa mère de mon fils oui
mais voilà donc c'est je pense que avec
le recul c'est vraiment le last
chèrement de métier qui nous a foutu en
l'air intérêts voilà mes jeux il en
parle avec mes valeurs je peux pas dire
des ddd des trémolos dans les yeux parce
qu on a vécu à date vraiment à 2000 à
l'heure pendant quatre ans c'était une
vie de fruits c'était vraiment j'avais
quelques vous avez pris la voiture de
lyon